okay so the trailer for secret invasion
is now out and throughout this video
we're gonna be breaking down the Easter
eggs in it what happens in the comics
and also our general thoughts on the
first look below there's a lot of things
to talk about and the Nick Fury Focus
project is going to be centered around
the secret Invasion by the Scrolls and a
lot of high-ranking government positions
the show will be more of a thriller
similar to the Winter Soldier which I
think is one of the best MCU movies ever
made we're gonna be going over it all
but they'll also be heavy spoilers in
this video due to us talking about what
we've heard on some of the characters
there are rumors and scroll names
floating around so if you don't want
those potentially ruined then I
recommend that you turn off now without
the way huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into secret invasion
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
stepping off an alien ship and if you
cast your mind back to the ending of Far
From Home then you'll remember that he
was traveling with the Scrolls Talos was
of course masquerading as him in the
movie and he's also back to being in the
same form that he was in Captain Marvel
must save a ton on makeup and it means
that Ben Mendelson can reprise his role
as the head of Shield do you know why no
one is asking why he isn't 30 years
older but maybe they're in on it too now
judging by what they say in the teaser I
actually think Fury might have been away
longer than it appears to be they kind
of touch upon that in the teaser and we
may discover that he disappeared after
the events of Winter Soldier or even Age
of Ultron the Funko Pop for the
character has him looking like when he
went Incognito and they may reveal he's
been off world for quite some time now
if we discovered he went before the
events of Winter Soldier then that could
even explain why he was able to survive
being shot in that Maria said that she's
tried to contact him several times for
hell but he's let those calls go to
voicemail you see kids you don't ghost
Nick Fury Nick Fury ghosts you we then
watch him traveling about to his
contacts including Roadie and we also
get a shot of Everett Ross in a similar
get-up to Fury showing that he's lying
low I'm not too sure on who this woman
is so let me know below if you know but
yeah she finds a gun in an envelope
clearly for her protection potentially
Nick sent this out to her or it could
have an even more Sinister side might
come to a point where she has to use it
on herself rather than being taken but
hey it's Marvel so it probably shoots
bubbles or something now I love this
shot when Talos grabs who I'm guessing
is a scroll leader and we watch all of
the punters at the restaurant morph into
Kingsley benedier we don't know who this
actor is playing but it's such a good
shot watching them all change even got
the staff there showing that they have
people everywhere now as for Roadie
he'll likely just be a cameo in the show
similar how he was in Falcon in the
Winter Soldier secret invasion of course
had major Heroes being revealed to be
Scrolls and with him being the the only
Avengers level character in it I think
maybe maybe it's him I've seen of
theories that this might be used to
explain the recasting in Iron Man 2 but
then he'd look like a different person
so I don't know why he'd shapeshift you
also have armor Wars coming up which
will be centered around the character so
I do think that Roadie will probably
remain human now as for the comics they
basically had secret Invasion as a major
event that spanned several book lines
and it was heavily centered around
Avengers and the X-Men we obviously know
from the first looking cast list that
they won't be in the show but they will
be taking the main theme of it and
applying it to the series now that
centers around a squirrel Invasion that
happens on the planet in the MCU skrulls
were portrayed as the good guys so my
theory is that there will be a faction
within them that wants to take over the
planet they were of course left as
refugees at the end of Captain Marvel
and there will be some who probably
think that they can just take over the
Earth instead now in case you haven't
read the book I want to talk about what
happens in it so you kind of have a
heads up over what could be popping up
in the show the work picked up in the
aftermath of Civil War and it began when
Nick Fury discovered that Scrolls and
infiltrate had major parts of society
inert the plan by Valentina alegrity
Fontaine where it seemed like she
planned to kill him in order to gain
access to secure Shield Intel Fury
struck first but she turned into a
scroll making him realize that they had
double agents amongst them this is
definitely something I could see popping
up in the show as Val has become a big
character and she will probably tie into
this in some way now Fury went into
hiding after realizing this and he ended
up sending Spider Woman into Shield to
keep an eye on things I think in the
show this role will be taken up by Maria
Hill who we know will be in the series
interestingly the comics revealed that
she was a skrull as well and as we know
won his poster said before at the time
Tony Stark had been put in charge of
Shield due to the events of Civil War
but here it looks like Talos is running
the show he of course appeared as Fury
before and can change into anyone that
he needs to Fury started investigating
things and we watched events play out
with Tony as he discovered the same
thing with Reed Richards and Hank Pym
Spider-Woman played some
four-dimensional chat and handed over
the body of an Elektra scroll which made
them start looking at things a lot
closer she told them she'd found a
crashed scroll ship in the Savage lands
and the group then ventured out there
this is when the Scrolls launched their
attack and there was a major fight at
one point Tony was even convinced that
he himself was a scroll and had been
hypnotized into thinking that he was the
real Stark this didn't turn out to be
true but I can't see them doing
something similar with Fury as he of
course has had scrawled poses him before
in the end several characters were
revealed as being shapeshifters and this
included Hank Pym Jarvis Mockingbird
dumb dumb dug in and even Spider-Woman
herself eventually the good guys won but
National Security was never the same and
the world faced another major crisis
Just Another Sunday night in the MCU but
yeah it had big ramifications on
everything else now who Olivia Coleman's
character is we don't know but there are
rumors about her according to leaks in
the show she will be playing a character
called Sonia falsworth and she will work
as the head of mi-13 mi-13 is a uk-based
agency that's obviously playing off MI5
and MI6 they deal with paranormal and
Supernatural activities and they've been
known to handle several alien invasions
which is why she's being brought into
the show possibly a scroll she will
likely be one of the big characters in
the series but is she good or bad let me
know below I know you want to let me
know now as for Amelia Clarke's
character we still know very little
about her she will however play a big
role in the series and again spoilers
for who this character could be take it
with a pinch of salt as we don't know
any of this stuff are definite but
Daniel rpk dropped the scoop saying that
she was a scroll known as Gaia this is a
character that pulls from the comics and
along with her fellow agent clue
emasqueraded as a family on Earth the
pair raised three daughters together and
were basically a Sleeper Cell similar to
Black Widow's family the entire lot of
them were hiding out on Earth waiting
for the invasion to kick off but one of
their daughters was taken by project
Blossom their kid Ivy was thought to be
dead but this later turned out to be a
and true facing this new enemy in
Project Blossom the pair tried to take
them down whilst also continuing their
mission of their secret Invasion the
pair even posed as Pepper Potts and Tony
Stark at one point and though I doubt
they'll do that in the show because he's
dead spoiler alert
I still think she's gonna be a big
character in the series potentially
she's even the key to taking down the
Scrolls and I can see her sort of
switching sides throughout anyway that's
the trailer and as for my thoughts on it
I'm very excited though it massively
seems to be different from the comics I
think if it's in the same vein as Winter
Soldier then it'll still be really
strong if you've watched my Disney Plus
show breakdowns and you'll know that
I've had my criticisms of the MC
releases but this could end up being
something special Samuel L Jackson is
obviously a massive star and hopefully
they're putting the work in to deliver
something worth him stepping under the
small screen for now I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the show so comment
below and let me know if you are any
competition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of September and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and comment below with
your thoughts on the teaser we pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
break Titan of She-Hulk which will be
linked on screen right now we go over
the major things in it talk about all
the Easter eggs and give our theories so
yeah head over there after this by the
way thanks for sticking through the
video love you Paul I'll see you next
time take care peace